this is really great when barack obama
was president
fox news said that executive orders were
tyranny they were tyrannical
when trump became president fox news
said
trump's executive orders are fine
because he has to undo
the tyranny that were barack obama's
executive orders
and now on day one joe biden signed 17
executive orders undoing some of the
worst of the worst of what donald trump
did
and once again fox news host ainslie
her feelings are hurt it is
wild how everybody's feelings
are now the most important thing on fox
news
and she doesn't think joe biden is
acting to unite america because
undoing trump's executive orders with
his own
is mean guys these people are so
childish and pathetic and predictable
take a look at this
our country's got to come together and
joe biden said yesterday
i want unity he talked about that in his
speech but the first thing he does the
first order of business
is to walk in sit down at the table and
he has 17 executive orders really wiping
away
much of what president trump did so his
supporters are saying how can we have
unity
if you're taking away everything that we
like this is so stupid
that it doesn't even count as as
political analysis
the things joe biden dealt with
yesterday on day one which i'm thrilled
to have seen him deal with
we're not just canceling
counterproductive things that donald
trump did
they were things that divided us from
the world if you want to talk about
unity
everybody's in the paris climate accord
we're out
that's divisive other countries are
taking covet seriously but we have a
president saying it's the flu
and it'll go away like a miracle and 15
cases will be zero
that's divisive in terms of the united
states from the rest of the world
we are going to have four solid years of
these people
whining that joe biden simply isn't
continuing everything trump did
if you follow what ainsley earhart is
saying to its logical conclusion
anything that joe biden does differently
than trump is apparently not unity and
that's right joe biden is not trump
these are the same people
who for four years under trump said
elections have consequences
and you lefties have to deal with it and
they were right during the trump era i
agreed
elections have consequences and that's
why it was tragic that so many leftists
stayed home in 2016. but the 2020
election also has consequences and we're
seeing them now and by the way
if ainsley is correct and on day one joe
biden really did undo everything donald
trump did
that confirms trump didn't do very much
if joe biden in four hours these were
signed within four hours
of joe biden being sworn in if in four
hours biden can undo
four years worth of what donald trump
did donald trump didn't do very much
and uh we are going just prepare
yourselves
this is what fox news or worse this is
what fox news is going to look like for
the next four years
let me know your reaction and your your
feedback to the early days of the biden
administration
i'm on twitter at deepakman regardless
of your
workout nutrition and diet goals it is
crucial to have the right amount of
protein in your diet and if you're
supplementing with protein powders you
should be sure you have the powder that
is right for you
and that's where our sponsor gainful
comes in gainful
offers customized protein based on your
body type
diet fitness habits and goals their
formulas are optimized
for you with simple and effective
ingredients no fillers
gluten soy or anything artificial and
gainful also gives you free
unlimited one-on-one access to your own
registered dietitian
which is a great bonus you won't find
anywhere else and my favorite part is
that gainful protein
is never repetitive or boring because
they will rotate the flavors you
choose like rich chocolate cookies and
cream
chocolate peanut butter strawberry cream
cafe mocha
i took their quiz and they gave me
protein tailored to my
specific needs everything was quick and
easy i've been loving what they sent me
you'll get fifteen dollars off your
first month
when you go to gainful.com pacman the
link is underneath this video